foreign
[Applause]
it's been two years since four neo-nazis
invaded my family's lake house and
murdered my father
I've run away from three foster homes
this is Elena Khan I've lived with her
for the past year
we go now to a developing story they
call themselves The nobleman
to Fillmore whether or not the nobleman
decide to make an appearance at the Town
Hall on Wednesday only time will tell so
are you gonna see this you're just gonna
stand there
right this way
finally
been on purpose
Diego
saving our country and stopping the
trees in one vengeful Mission at a time
to freedom freedom free freedom
[Music]
who is it
it's Becky
you took my dog
[Music]
should we go to the cops I got enough
Weaponry in my barn to start an
Insurrection at Town Hall tomorrow
please
find the girl you give her back her dog
[Music]
it was fun while it lasted that's not
over yet